[Musica]
nel 2019 la rivista medica lancet
riportava che il mondo non è più in
grado di fornire alle persone una dieta
sana ed allo stesso tempo mantenere le
risorse del pianeta da almeno 50 anni le
diete non sono più ottimali da un punto
di vista nutrizionale
da un lato contribuiscono al cambiamento
climatico e dall'altro accelerano il
processo di erosione della biodiversità
biodiversità che cosa vuol dire in
pratica si intende l'insieme degli
organismi viventi sia animali che
vegetali che sono intorno a noi
questo include anche i microorganismi
inclusi quelli che troviamo nel terreno
il cambiamento climatico e la perdita di
biodiversità insieme alla mancanza di
acqua povertà e malnutrizione dove per
malnutrizione intendiamo sia la
denutrizione che l'obesità sono tra i
problemi globali più discussi oggi
spesso si discute di questi problemi
indipendentemente in realtà sono molto
interconnessi e sono tutti collegati ai
semi cambiamento climatico si collega
con i seni perché nel tempo avremmo
bisogno di varietà di colture che so
resistono molto di più alle alte
temperature e dall'altra parte riescono
a crescere con meno acqua
il problema che non è così semplice il
cambiamento climatico è un problema
molto complesso
mentre da una parte ci sono modelli
climatici molto imprecisi per cui
sappiamo che farà più caldo e pioverà di
meno ma quanto più caldo è quantomeno
pioggia riceveremo nessuno ce lo può
dire
non solo a livello di grosse aree
geografiche ma anche in una specifica
località quindi brancoliamo un po nel
buio
quindi dobbiamo avere varietà quindi
l'obiettivo di un miglioramento genetico
è una varietà che resista a qualcosa che
non conosciamo e quindi è un obiettivo
mobile insieme a temperatura e piovosita
cambieranno anche malattie delle piante
insetti inclusi anche gli impollinatori
e cambieranno le infestanti per cui
dobbiamo lavorare per avere varietà che
vanno meglio a temperature più alte e
ameno piovosità ma dobbiamo lavorare
anche per altri obiettivi quindi il
tutto diventa una cosa molto complessa
lavorare per obiettivi mobili ed allo
stesso tempo diversi obiettivi per avere
nuove varietà per il futuro
nel caso della riduzione della
biodiversità
il problema è un po una contraddizione
che la scienza ci pone
mentre da una parte abbiamo regolarmente
delle relazioni dei lavori che ci dicono
che è importante avere biodiversità
nella nostra dieta ma anche per riuscire
a contrastare meglio il cambiamento
climatico
dall'altra parte negli ultimi 60 o 70
anni abbiamo lavorato riducendo il
numero di specie all'interno delle poche
specie coltivate coltiviamo poche
varietà e per di più queste varietà sono
uniformi quindi tutte le piante
all'interno di un campo sono uguali
l'una all'altra
quindi siamo andati esattamente
all'opposto di quello che ci serve
la biodiversità è importante per la
nostra salute perché una dieta diversa
fa bene alla nostra salute e quindi
biodiversità e cambiamento climatico
sono collegati fra di loro e sono
collegati ai semi però cosa è successo
abbiamo detto siamo andati verso
l'uniformità l'agricoltura industriale
oggi ci porta sempre all'uniformità
quale potrebbe essere una soluzione
sicuramente dobbiamo riportare
biodiversità nei campi degli agricoltori
è una possibilità è quella di riportare
a coltivare quelle che a me piacciono
definire come cv intelligenti da colture
intelligenti ma cosa sono i cibi
intelligenti può essere un cibo
intelligente un cibo intelligente è un
cibo che fa bene a chi lo mangia nello
stesso tempo aiuta a ridurre le
emissioni per cui fa bene all'ambiente
in generale fa bene al pianeta ma è
anche un cibo che fa reddito per
l'agricoltore quindi anche buono per
l'agricoltore in altre parole un cibo
buono
buono per l'ambiente è buono per
l'agricoltore
ma come mai negli anni molte di queste
colture che ci danno cibi intelligenti
sono scomparse dal nostro panorama
agricolo ci sono stati negli anni
investimenti nella ricerca nelle
politiche di sviluppo e nello sviluppo
delle filiere che hanno privilegiato un
numero ristretto di colture per esempio
oggi per parlare di cereali mais
frumento e riso rappresentano più del 60
per cento delle calorie di origine
vegetale che mangiamo a livello globale
quindi nel tempo le diete si sono sono
diventate molto più simili lune alle
altre e per di più sono diventate simili
anche a livello geografico per cui
mangiamo le stesse cose e dappertutto ma
quali possono essere per esempio colture
intelligenti da riportare dai nostri
agricoltori
voglio fare l'esempio del miglio e
dell'orzo che una volta erano molto
utilizzati nelle nostre campagne e molto
utilizzati nella nostra alimentazione
milio ed orzo hanno grossi vantaggi
nutrizionali sono molto più nutrienti
per esempio di frumento mais e riso
contengono micro nutrienti importanti
per la nostra dieta sono molto più
digeribili rispetto ad altri cereali
quindi sono buoni per la nostra salute
sono buoni per chi li usa queste colture
hanno anche meno bisogno per esempio di
acqua di fertilizzanti di chimica in
generale per cui vi contribuiscono a
ridurre le emissioni che poi
contribuiscono al cambiamento climatico
quindi fanno bene per l'ambiente fanno
bene al pianeta
queste colture abbiamo visto che nel
momento in cui vengono riportate nei
campi di agricoltori sono anche capaci
di fare reddito per l'agricoltore purché
se ne crei una richiesta e quindi siano
accettate dal mercato contribuiscono
alla diversità dell'azienda per cui
contribuiscono a introdurre della
resilienza nel caso dell'azienda
possiamo però anche riportare diversità
nei campi dell'agricoltura coltivando
colture in cui abbiamo diversità
all'interno della stessa cultura
introdurre quindi quelle che chiamiamo
popolazioni evolutive che cosa sono
sono tantissime piante della stessa
specie coltivate insieme nello stesso
terreno
siccome abbiamo tantissime piante
diverse queste nel tempo tendono alcune
tendono a produrre di più altre tendono
a produrre di meno e quindi la stessa
popolazione si evolve nello stesso
terreno
anno dopo anno se le distribuiamo ad
agricoltori diversi queste si
evolveranno in maniera diversa anche
negli altri agricoltori
quindi avremo diversità sia nel tempo in
una stessa località
ma anche nello spazio in uno stesso anno
esperienze con popolazioni evolutive in
iran e successivamente anche in italia
hanno mostrato che il pane prodotto con
farina di una popolazione evolutiva di
frumento tenero e molto più digeribile e
molto apprezzato sia per sapore che per
profumo in italia in aggiunta al pane di
frumento tenero abbiamo anche la pasta
prodotta da una popolazione di frumento
duro quindi sono buone per il
consumatore quindi sono buone per noi
per la nostra salute
inoltre quando coltiviamo popolazioni
evolutive in un campo essendo composte
da piante tutte diverse
queste controllano meglio malattie
insetti ed infestanti quindi richiedono
pochissimi pesticidi a volte non
richiedono ha fatto l'uso di pesticidi
questo vuol dire meno emissioni e quindi
aiutano a mitigare l'effetto negativo
del cambiamento climatico
quindi sono buone per il pianeta sono
buone per l'ambiente le popolazioni
evolutive sono anche buone per
l'agricoltore perché non avendo bisogno
di grandi input di quindi di grande
chimica riducono i costi di produzione
quindi l'agricoltore può risparmiare sui
costi di produzione inoltre danno
l'agricoltore la possibilità di adattare
la propria cultura al cambiamento
climatico quindi da un anno all'altro
l'agricoltore fuori seminare i semi da
sé prodotti e avendo sempre una
produzione più alta perché i semi
prodotti l'anno prime re seminati l'anno
dopo sono sempre più adatti alle
condizioni in cui vengono seminati
i prodotti che si ottengono da
popolazioni evolutivi sono molto
apprezzati dai consumatori e quindi
possono fare reddito ed hanno
contribuito e questa è un'esperienza che
abbiamo visto soprattutto in italia a
costruire delle filiere locali molto
virtuose
in conclusione abbiamo bisogno di
sviluppare la ricerca e le filiere di
altre colture incluse le popolazioni
evolutive
in questo modo possiamo riportare
diversità nella nostra dieta
possiamo aumentare la sostenibilità
ambientale dell'agricoltura e gli
agricoltori possono far leva su questa
nuova diversità per avere molto più
resilienza in azienda
in altre parole il cibo intelligente
aiuta ad affrontare alcuni dei grandi
problemi globali però affinché ciò
accada
dobbiamo usare un approccio
partecipativo in cui sia l'agricoltore
che il consumatore con tutti gli attori
intermedi della filiera siano parte per
sviluppare questo nuovo approccio
ovviamente la scuola e l'addestramento
hanno un ruolo fondamentale e facendo
tutto questo potremmo riportare un
modello di business positivo nelle
nostre aziende
[Musica]